>> Alan Eustace: So hello, everybody. And
welcome. I have the amazingly great pleasure
of introducing Al Worden here. Here's his
book Falling To Earth. Which you should all
run out and buy then you should tell all your
friends to buy. How's that.
>>Al Worden: Good morning Alan. Thank you.
[laughter]
>> Eustace: [laughter] In a matter of fact
I'll sell mine for 55 dollars right now and
it will be worth every penny.[laughter] No,
no. As I was telling him, I sent a note around.
I grew up with the space program. My dad and
I moved and my mom from Baltimore, Maryland
down to Orlando, Florida so he could work
at Martin Marietta as a mechanical engineer
in an aerospace company. And we went to essentially
every launch. So we would all pile into the
car and drive over to the coast, which was
maybe 50 miles away, something like that.
Back in the day you could watch launches from
really, really close. And you know I still
get goose pimples when I think about those
launches and think about the period of time
when I think there was a revolution in technology
and science and exploration and things like
that. And I'm just so happy to have you here
as a participant-
>> Worden: Thank you Alan.
>> Eustace: In that program. So you guys are
going to ask most of the questions. I just
want you to know that. So if any of you just
sitting there waiting for everyone around
to ask all the question or even worse waiting
for me to ask all the questions. You guys
are going to have to start thinking right
away. But I do have a few here just to get
us started. I'll start actually with one of
the ones here which I know is near and dear
to your heart, which is navigation. So we,
you know, having, you know getting to the
Moon and getting back, you know, was, well,
why don't you actually start with the computers,
how much support you had in that process.
And then talk about navigation in general.
>> Worden: Okay, obviously to go to the Moon,
you got to know where you are. You got to
know where the Moon is. [laughter] Which is
kind of an interesting problem. We knew where
we were launching from. We knew where we were
going, and we kind of had to keep track of
where we were on the way. We had a computer
on board that we used to help us make all
those calculations and in fact we could do
our own navigation on board. Let me say this,
there's a difference between the way the American
space program is operated and the way the
Russians are operated. The Russians basically
do everything from the ground. Everything
is remotely controlled. We have a lot of unmanned
aerial vehicles these days that are run from
a console somewhere outside of Las Vegas,
I guess. It's kind of same thing. The Russians
fly their spacecraft from their mission control.
And those on board I guess would, could take
over in emergency of some kind, but basically
they're not trained to do that. As a matter
of fact, the first Cosmonauts flown in space
some of them weren't even pilots. If you're
familiar at all with the Russian space program
there was a gal who flew early in the program.
Her name was Valentina Tereshkova and her
qualification for making that space flight
is that she was the best parachutist in her
club.
[groans from audience]
Because back in those days, they had to bail
out at 10,000 feet down on their way down
otherwise they're going to crash into the
Earth in that little spacecraft they had.
Anyway, we fly everything on board in this
country. Anything we do in space is actually
flown by hand on board or flown by an on board
computer in some way with a guy backing that
up. So we had a computer on board to help
us do those things. And that computer was,
it was designed back in the 1950s. It was
a small, hand-wired computer that fit into
the instrument panel and had a little disk
key with buttons on it that we could interface
with the computer. And for all the activity,
for all the stuff we asked that computer to
do, it had a programmable memory of 75K.
>>Eustace: So you should also tell them what
program was left out of the hard code.
>>Worden: Well-
>>Eustace: That you had to-
>>Worden: Right-
>>Eustace: Load later just in case you might
need it.
>> Worden: Yeah, they didn't have enough computer
capacity to put all the programs in that we
needed to go to the Moon and come back. So
they left one out and it was the called the
return to Earth program. [laughter] Which
might have been a little problem if we lost
our communications. That's where we would
have a problem. But we were very success-oriented
so it didn't slow us down any. But what the
computer did for us is it calculated angles
and location for us. Now, if you, you want
me to go into navigation? We used three reference
systems to make the flight. The first one
is of course an Earth-centered system so when
we're in Earth orbit, the center of the Earth
is the center of the system. It's an orthogonal
system, XYZ coordinates, standard old orthogonal
coordinate system. When we started on our
way to the Moon we switched to a sun-centered
system. Same thing XYZ coordinates, but it
was a sun-centered system because the Earth
and the Moon and us, we're all in that solar
system. And then as we got closer to the Moon,
we switched over to a lunar-centered system.
So we basically used three different reference
frames to get from the Earth to the Moon.
Now, we were in the sun-centered system most
of the time and that's where we did most of
the navigation. The navigation was fairly
straightforward. There were two ways of doing
it. One was mission control could tell us.
They had what they called state vector. And
that's as you know, that's position, velocity,
and time, okay? So you got three axis, three
coordinates of position, three of velocity
and one of time.
We could do essentially the same thing in
space, but we did it in entirely different
way. When mission control, as they were watching
us, they did all of their calculations based
on ground measurements. There were 3 large
space telescopes around the world at 120 degrees
so that one of them was always locked on to
the spacecraft all the time. There were a
couple of things that they look for. One was
they look for range and range rate and the
other is they look for direction. Kind of
interesting as I'm telling that one. As I'm
writing the book I'm trying to sort all this
out and I'm talking to all the people that
worked in mission control back in the days
when we make our flight and I come to find
out that they didn't understand this ground
system. Mission control they spent 90% of
their time talking about range and range rate,
which gave them our position plus our velocity
and they were very accurate. It was a pseudo-random
range signal that they sent up and it got
turned around in a certain way and when they
read that return they could calculate where
we were and how fast we were moving. The other
component of course is direction and that's
the one mission control completely missed
20 years later. They forgot all about direction.
They kept thinking it was just range and range
rate but it was direction. I finally tracked
down a guy who was manager of one of the space
station, one of the large space stations in
Australia and he said of course we sent the
trinion angles to Goddard spacecraft center
in Maryland they then translated them into
the other three large space telescopes so
they had the trinion angles to point to when
the Earth's rotated and the spacecraft came
into view they had the trinion angles to go
to.
In flight, we did it a little differently.
We relied solely on the solar system and the
stars. We had 37 stars in the sky that were
the brightest; the 37 brightest stars and
they were our navigation stars. What I would
do in flight, I was kind of the navigator.
What I would do in flight is I would find
one of the stars in the telescope and then
find the second star and we had a sexton on
board. I could lock on to those two stars,
superimpose one on the other. The computer
would then calculate the angle. Now what that
gave us if we do that orthogonally, actually
I did it in every direction I could find.
You always want to do one more. [laughter]
You're never satisfied with the last result
you got. But what that did is that gave us
an attitude within the solar system, just
attitude. That's all. Make sure we're pointed
in the right direction. Now, to get location
in the Earth-Moon system, you have to do something
slightly different. Now, we take a star and
we calculate the angle between the star and
the near or far horizon of the Earth or the
Moon. And that then triangulates or gives
us a location within the Earth-Moon system.
That's not as simple as it might sound. The
Earth is about 8,000 miles across. The Earth's
atmosphere is 50 miles thick. When you compare
50 miles to 8,000 miles, it's not very big.
But that 50 miles difference is enough to
kill you on the way back, okay? You cannot
afford to have that kind of slack in your
calculations. So, what we did is, we picked
a color band in the Earth's horizon to do
this sighting on. I found that the color band
blue, there's a light blue band of color around
the Earth, and I found that I could find that
repeatedly and I could use that as one anchor
and then pick the star with the other side
and bring those together and it would calculate
locations. So that's the nav system on board
which is very different from the ground which
only uses radio telescope data to tell where
you are. In other words direction and range
and range rate and it can tell very accurate.
In fact, the ground had us within probably
I think 4 meters, well, more than that. Let's
see, ten meters in about four meters per second.
That's what they had us all the time. And
it's a darn good thing they did that as we're
getting close to the Moon we never saw it.
We were going in backwards. So we never saw
it. [laughter] So it was nice we had confidence
they had this thing calculated well. Yeah.
>> Eustace: Well that's great. One of the
things I thought was unusual about your book
is you told it from the perspective of the
command module pilot. And I think that's one
of the least understood roles in all the Apollo
launches. So why don't you talk about the
different roles of the different people.
>> Worden: You know there are two different
ways of looking at the things that the various
guys did on flights: there's the way from
the Houston approach, the mission approach,
the astronaut approach, and then there's the
media approach. And the media has a very different
take on what people do and how they do it
on a flight then what really happened. The
truth is that well, the ground rule was that
you always had to have two people on board.
One doing the flying the other looking over
his shoulder to make everything is okay when
you're doing a dynamic maneuver like flying
the Lunar module down to the surface. That's
a dynamic maneuver and it required two people
on board. I stayed in orbit and that was okay
because I didn't really do a lot of maneuvering.
That's why we had three people on a flight,
okay? The commander on a flight like Dave
Scott was on our flight is the guy who flies
the lunar module down to the surface successfully
and then they get out and they walk around
for two, three days then they get back in
it and they come back in a hurry. He's responsible
for flying the lunar module down. They fly
it like a helicopter. Jim Irwin was the Lunar
module pilot. He was a systems engineer. He
didn't get a chance to fly anything. Command
module pilots guy gets to fly everything.
That's what I liked. I flew everybody out.
Dave Scott actually was in command during
the first 12 minutes of the flight. That's
till we got into orbit. Then it's my job.
>>Eustace: Tell 'em what Dave Scott's role
was in all-
>>Worden: Dave Scott's role on launch was
basically to put his hand on the abort handle
and be ready to twist it. And my job on the
launch was to hold his hand [laughter] and
make sure he didn't. [laughter] It didn't
really make a whole heck of a lot of difference
whether he was in the left seat or not. It
would have been his decision. If something
had gone wrong on the launch, it would have
been his decision to abort. And Jim and I
both agreed we weren't going to let him do
that. But anyway, his job was to fly the Lunar
module down to the surface and back again.
My job was to fly them all out there, stay
in orbit by myself while they were down on
the surface. Then when they come back into
Lunar orbit while they rendezvoused, I docked.
Then I got to fly them all the way back home.
Like I say, I got most of what they call stick
time. [chuckle] Now, there's a difference
in the perception of what each crew member
does as far as what the public sees. I mean,
we talk about Moon walkers a lot. There are
12 Moon walkers. The guy I flew with tried
to make a big deal about there being 12 Moon
walkers. That's a rather significant number.
He founded a Christian fellowship organization
kind of based on 12 Moon walkers. Jim you're
crazy. But that's another story. But the lunar
module pilot really was kind of along for
the ride. Basically there was never a design
in a program for a lunar module pilot to ever
be the commander. He had to become a command
module pilot first because you got to learn
one of the systems. You got to learn it and
fly it. You got to live with it. You got to
make it work for you. Command module pilot
does that with the command service module
and then what he's got to do if me becomes
a commander he's got to learn to fly the Lunar
module. So he's only got one more thing to
learn. Lunar module pilot never has a chance
to fly anything, so he's got to learn both
of them. That's too much, that's too big a
job. So there was never a program for Lunar
module pilot to fly as a commander. And command
module pilot was shortcut to become command
pilot. That could have happened except they
canceled the program out on us so we never
got the chance.
>> Eustace: So good. So one of the things
that, you know, comes up a lot is what's it
like in space? What was your life like?
>> Worden: We were, we were in a vehicle that
was about the size of a Volkswagen beetle.
We had 220 cubic feet to play with. I'll give
you some comparisons. Mercury spacecraft,
the very first one for one guy had 40 cubic
feet of space for that one guy. Anybody here
know what volume is in a casket? [laughter]
Well, it happens to be about 40 cubic feet.
Gemini Program came along that's a 2 man program.
And I'll talk about that for a minute in a
little bit. But the Gemini Program came along
and that was I believe 75 cubic feet for 2
of them. So that's like 37½ cubic feet for
each of them. Then the Apollo program came
and that was man it was a Cadillac of the
spacecraft. [laughter] It had 220 cubic feet
for three of us. So we had as much space as
one person would have had in a Gemini capsule
all by himself. 220 cubic feet of space, that's
about what you find in a Volkswagen beetle.
And it's kind of interesting. You think about
what it would be like, we train for three
years for this flight. We train in simulators.
And we trained together. We did all of that.
And you think to yourself what it would be
like to be in that thing for two weeks with
these guys. And you really can't quite come
to any sensible understanding. But you find
out when you get there. [laughter] You know,
it's the difference of getting in a simulator
for eight hours and then going home as opposed
to being in this thing 24/7 with no way out.
So, you learn to do things. I learn to ignore
the other two guys. [laughter] Basically that
was my survival mode. It was just kind of
ignore them.
>>Eustace: Well in your book you said when
they left for the Moon, you just kind of relaxed.
It's like finally some time alone.
>>Worden: Well, well, that's kind of in response
to questions I get from people. You know a
lot of people say, "command module pilot,
you were in lunar orbit by yourself for three
days. You got to be the loneliest guy in the
world. It's got to be tough." And I'm very
quick to point out that's the best time of
the flight. [laughter] I got rid of those
two guys for three days. And when I was behind
the Moon, I didn't even have to talk to mission
control.
[audience laughter]
So I was very happy by myself. [laughter]
Living in space is, this may turn out to be
the biggest problem that we've got to face
if we really do long-term flights. I think
the technology will come along. I think we'll
be able to handle that. But I think the psychological
and the physiological side of long-term space
flight is going to be the thing that we're
going to have to really face up to. In two
weeks not enough happens to you. It's not
really a problem. But if we go for three years,
like going to Mars, that's going to be a problem.
Now, the things that we had to kind of figure
out on our flight, in the first place, you
all know the term zero G. You've heard it.
Zero gravity. And you also all understand
I'm sure that there's no such thing. There's
no zero gravity anywhere. I don't care where
you are. There's no zero gravity. You can
get that out of your mind right now. What
we were in our entire flight was free fall.
Exactly the same condition as if we were to
put ourselves inside a barrel and go over
Niagara Falls. You're in free fall going down.
Now, the reason they kind of call it zero
G is that the relationship between you and
the can you're in, you're both going the same
direction same time same speed, right? So
you respect to the can are floating around
and it's like zero gravity, okay? That's how
that term got started. But in reality, there's
no such thing. You're in free fall, but so
is the can you're in. So you're floating inside
and you got to learn all these different things
you really never thought about before. Going
to sleep the first night, it was kind of an
interesting experience. We had sleeping bags.
They were made out of fishnet type material.
The whole sleeping bag probably didn't weigh
more than four ounces, very, very flimsy but
in this free fall condition, you don't need
much. It had strings at each end. They were
like shoelaces. And you are to tie the shoelaces
to something in the spacecraft to stretch
this thing out and I decided I'd do something
different. So I got a paperclip and I tied
the string to a paperclip on each end. And
I just hooked the paper clip over a bolt head
on either end. That would stretch out the
sleeping bag and I'd slide in it. The sleeping
bags were made only to come up to your neck.
So I slid into the sleeping bag the first
night with my head outside and tried to go
to sleep. Well, that's a little bit of a problem.
We are used to certain thing here on Earth.
And gravity is one of them. [laughter] Right?
And it's hard to imagine what it's like if
that gravity is not working on you, but we
go to bed at night here on Earth. We get into
bed. We put our head on a pillow. Son of a
gun, it stays there. Why? Because gravity
is holding it down, right? When you get into
space and you're kind of in this free fall
environment, there's nothing to hold your
head down. So if the sleeping bag comes up
to your neck, you lay there and you try to
go to sleep, all of a sudden you find your
head is starting to wander again. And you
realize that your head's got a mind of its
own. It's just kind of doing certain things.
So the first night out I had to unzip the
sleeping bag put my head where my shoulder
would be which is a little shorter than I
am and zip it back up and I slept easily.
How many of you ever just as you were falling
asleep had the feeling of falling off a cliff?
Anybody ever done that? I think we all have,
we just don't want to admit it. This is exactly
what we're doing is falling off that cliff
in free fall. That's exactly what we're doing.
Second night not so bad. Third night didn't
even need the sleeping bag. Humans are very
adaptable and we get into this space thing
physically very easily. As a matter of fact,
it was such -after a couple of days of adjustment,
it was so much like home that I had a kind
of thing in the back of my head gosh I've
been here kind of thing it's like déjà vu
and it makes you wonder if there's not a little
genetic thing in our brains that says, "Hey,
you know, we've been here before." Anyway,
that's for another time. [chuckles] But anyway,
that's, by the third night I could just curl
up in a ball go to sleep anywhere, very easy.
The next thing was food. And I'm going to
take you through the whole God dang bloody
mess here so just bear with me. [laughter]
The next thing is food. We had freeze-dried
food mostly. We had some that was radiated
like roast beef, and hot dogs hamburgers.
But most of the food was freeze-dried. It
was made by a company up in Michigan called
Whirlpool Corporation. And they made some
300 different varieties of freeze-dried food.
We had to test all this food before the flight
to see if there was anything we were not compatible
with obviously. Something that wasn't good
for us. So I tasted all 300 different kinds
of freeze-dried food. And I filled out a question
sheet. And our dietitian down in Houston,
Rita, wanted to know how we were doing. So
I gave her back the list. And she says, you
know, we're going to make menus for you. I
mean, looking at me. Well, that's great. So
two weeks before the flight, I get my menu.
Jim Erwin is my roommate. He's the guy who
flew with me. We compared menus just for the
fun of it and they were the same. [laughter]
So we went to Dave Scott, looked to his menu,
compared them and they were the same. [laughter]
I think Rita has handed us a bunch of you
know what. Let's go check the menu for the
Apollo 14 crew. And guess what? They're all
the same. It's government food. The issue
was that, if you absolutely couldn't stand
something, they'd take it off from everybody.
But the menus were all constant. They were
all the same menu, consistent. Anyway, food
is kind of an interesting thing. Oh, incidentally.
Drink. We had always this freeze-dried food,
but we also had drinks on board. Anybody know
what kind of drinks we had? Tang, yeah. Let
me just mention tang. [laughter] The last
time I had a swallow of Tang was over 40 years
ago [laughter] on my way back home from the
Moon and that was only because it's the only
thing I had. I decided after that that I had
never, never ever have that stuff again. It
was terrible. I like coffee. So I had freeze-dried
coffee made up. And I had freeze-dried coffee
black, with cream, and then with cream and
sugar. Depending on my mood then I'd get out
the kind. After dinner I like milk shake and
so I'd get out the cream and sugar. I'd talk
with Dave Scott and Jim Irwin; the guys that
I flew with and asked what are you going to
drink on the flight? I'm takin' coffee. I
have to have my coffee. I wake up every morning.
The only way I get my heart started in the
morning is to have a cup of coffee. "Oh, we're
going to drink hot chocolate." "Oh my God,
why?" "Well, we don't want to have caffeine."
We're not going to touch that caffeine in
coffee. We don't want that. Boy I tell you
what you're going to drink hot chocolate three
times a day for two weeks? I really wonder
if you can do that. "Oh yeah, we're going
to drink it all the time." Off we go. I got
my coffee. They got their hot chocolate. Three
days into the flight I'm checking my coffee
supply. It's way low. [laughter] So we had
a little confrontation about that. I had to
kind of hide it after that because they were
drinking my coffee. But this is the kind of
thing you run into in flight. Now the food,
the freeze-dried food, that's kind of fun.
For a meal we'd have maybe five bags of food
each, okay? There'd be like a soup and a salad
and an entree and then a desert, whatever,
five bags. You got to reconstitute the stuff.
I mean, it's hard as a brick when you get
it, right? It's if a plastic bag. It's got
a little nozzle or a little opening like an
inflation valve on a bicycle. And you got
to stick the water gun. We did have hot and
cold running water on board. We generated
our own water as we went. I'm sure you're
familiar with all. Not the kind you're thinking.
No, we got our energy from fuel cells. And
the fuel cells used hydrogen and oxygen and
the by-product is water. We got electricity
and water. So we had our fuel tank. And then,
we had probably the first instant hot water.
If you squeeze the trigger on the little switch
on the, it was like a pistol. So you go to
hot. Squeeze the trigger, you get one ounce
of hot water. Squeeze it again, you get the
next. So, if the package says four ounces
of hot water, you go squeeze, squeeze, squeeze,
squeeze and that's the way you got it. So
you reconstitute all five bags. Now there's
three of us on board so that's 15 bags of
food and it takes a while for this stuff to
reconstitute. So we're waiting for 20 minutes
probably. What do you do with 15 bags of food
in space while you're waiting for it to reconstitute?
Well, we tried every scheme we could think
of. We went to Velcro and that got to be complicated.
Actually we went to a clothesline and clothes
pins for one try. And he didn't like that.
Finally we decided the best thing was to just
let them go. Let them float. We didn't realize
this on the ground, but when we got into space,
we figured out that the air conditioning system
inside a command module blew the air around
in a circular fashion inside if spacecraft.
[laughter] And so we just put the food in
that and it would just go bum-bum-bum [laughter]
like a big lazy Susan. All you had to do was
wait for your color code. Our food was all
color coded red, white, and blue. Each of
us had a color. Dave was blue Jim was red
and I'm white. Obviously, I'm the good guy.
So anyway you wait till a bag comes by. It's
got a little white tab on it. You pull it
out of the stream. Cut the tab. Eat the food.
Now, here's another thing about the gravity.
There's a difference in this business when
you get into space. Why is a spoon designed
the way it is? [laughter] We don't often think
of these things, right? But there's the truth.
Here's the truth about this. Spoons have been
around as long as people, I think. But a spoon
is designed to take advantage of gravity,
right? You with me? [laughter] What do you
think happens in space? Well, there are couple
of other phenomena that work with this. A
spoon, you take say soup and you get a spoonful
of soup and you can hold it. The soup's pretty
level and you can hold it and it stays there,
right? Gravity keeps it in. When you go in
space, there are two other things working
for you. One is the adhesion of the liquid
to the bowl of spoon. We actually carried
regular soup spoons with us on flight. Adhesion
keeps it in, you know, sticks to the spoon.
Surface tension then holds the top of it.
But you don't get a level spoonful. You get
a big ball of soup on your spoon, okay? And
that ball of soup that's on your spoon is
a function of what surface tension is that
holds it there, okay? So you get your, you
dip it into the bag. You get your spoonful
of soup and you got this ball of soup. And
if it's too hot, you just let go of it for
a while. We wouldn't think of doing that down
here. But up there, you just let go of it
and it kind of floats around. As long as it
doesn't bang into something, it comes back
to ya and it's a little cooler and you can
eat it. [laughter] Well, we did have a problem
one day. We had tomato soup one day. And the
bag got popped open a little too fast and
it broke the surface tension of the soup inside
the bag. And the whole portion of soup came
out of the bag and it was a bag about this
big around. And you know it's really kind
of interesting to watch these things happen
in space because that ball is a perfect sphere.
And it kind of just start floating around.
Probably the most serious thing that happened
to us on the flight was that ball of soup.
That was almost panicsville, because if that
ball of soup gets behind an instrument panel
and breaks the surface tension. Now you got
a thousand little balls floating around shorting
out electric components. That's not a good
thing. Now, I maintain this is why we send
people into space is to solve these kinds
of problems. [laughter] We are never going
to have -- the one thing I found out about
making a space flight is that the problem
you're going to have in flight is something
you never thought about before flight; always
going to be something different than you had
figured out. Well, that ball of soup floating
around was one of them. You know you can't
touch it with a spoon because the minute you
touch it, you break surface tension. Now you've
got 1,000. Can't go after it with a straw.
What do you suppose we did?
>>Eustace: I know, I read the book. [laughter]
>>Worden: Agh! Very simple solution, got a
towel wrapped it around it and absorbed it.
Simple solution but you tell me a robot that
can figure that out. I don't think it would
do it because it's always going to be the
very unusual kinds of problems that crop up
on a flight. And that was one of them. Okay.
So we've got all this food. We've been eating
three squares a day. One of the problems initially
in space is not being hungry. And again, that's
function of gravity. When you eat a meal,
that meal sets on the bottom of your stomach
and the sensors on the bottom of your stomach
in our one gravity environment tell you you're
full. When the food's all gone, those sensors
say, "Gee, I'm hungry. I need something in
there to fill it up," right? When you're in
space, those sensors don't work because there's
no gravity acting on it. So the first few
days you have to force yourself to eat and
drink. I think that if anything happened on
the Apollo flights to the Moon, the one thing
that was constant to all of them was everybody
lost weight. Nobody gained weight on those
flights. And it's usually a question of dehydration
and not eating the food they're supposed to
eat. We forced fed ourselves the first couple
of days until our systems got used to that
no gravity kind of indication telling us we're
hungry. And once you get over that, then it's
not too bad. Okay. Now we come to the end
of the story. What happens after you've eaten
enough and you've drank enough. Sooner or
later, you have to do something else, right?
[laughter] That is, we decided before our
flight we were going to be explorers. We were
not going to be shy about anything, right?
Well, find out that taking a lot of willpower
when you get into flight. But let me tell
you how we disposed of the waste, right? The
urine was easy. We just had relief tubes just
like in an airplane. And that relief tube
dumped into a plastic bag, a reservoir if
you will. And you just keep adding to that
over a couple of days and then at some point
in the flight, you open a valve to the outside
and the vacuum sucks that all out, okay? So
then you cycle over and you start all over
again. The interesting thing when all that
stuff gets sucked out, the interesting thing
is it's kind of a surprise. Because what you
see outside the window is a cloud of snow.
It's a white cloud of snow. It's not yellow.
It's white. And that cloud of snow is unfortunately
going the same direction, the same time the
same speed you are. [laughter] So unless we
made a little mid-course maneuver somewhere
along the line, we got that cloud of snow
to keep track of. One of the reasons that's
why in our flight plan, we put in mid-course
corrections to coincide with urine dumps afterwards
so that we'd get away from it. Now, we've
taken care of the liquid. How about the solid
stuff in well, that's a little different.
We had plastic bags. Now, I'm telling you
this now. This is the way it is, right? If
you don't want to know the way it is, then
please leave. But we had plastic.
>> Eustace: This is where technology comes
in handy.
>> Worden: We didn't have that. Anyway. Plastic
bags. In these plastic bags were about this
long, about that big around. And on the open
end, they had an inch and a half flange that
was adhesive.
>> Eustace: Is this a demonstration?
>> Worden: Need I explain that anymore? I
tell you what. It was, it's kind of interesting
sitting in my seat and watching Dave float
by with that bag. I mean, you got [laughter]
I don't want to draw a picture. I want you
to draw your own picture of this. [laughter]
But I'll tell you. That up close and personal
stuff is really pretty bad. Anyway, okay.
But here's the deal. When you're done, you've
made your dump, okay. Now, when you're done,
you clean yourself up. You put that all back
in that in this plastic bag. You seal the
adhesive part. Then you got to take out a
pen and write your name on the bag and the
time of flight because the doctors back in
Houston, they're determined they're going
to analyze all that crap after the flight.
So we got to save it. Well I'm going to tell
you what happened to ours, because it never
got back to Earth. So anyway, that's kind
of like what it's like to live in space. And
you get used to it. Our diurnal cycle stayed
the same as Houston. We stayed on the same
time as Houston so when they went to sleep
at night we went to sleep. How you decide
that its night in space is you put the shutters
up in the windows, that's it because the sun
is always up there. We had a problem with
thermal heating on the way out and on the
way back from the Moon. If you stay in one
attitude and let the sun shine on just one
side of the spacecraft, you got a problem
because the temperature on that surface is
going to go to 350 and the temperature on
the shadowed side, the other side is going
to drop to about minus 250. So you got a 600
degree temperature differential across that
spacecraft and I don't think anybody trusted
it that much. So what we did is on the way
out we had the lunar module stuck on our nose
and we turned perpendicular to the plane of
the ecliptic. And we just slowly rotated about
once every two minutes just to keep that heating
rate constant around the outside of the spacecraft.
And of course, the terminology was that was
the barbecue maneuver [laughter] which is
kind of true. But that's how we took care
of the thermal issue on the way out to the
Moon. Once we got out in lunar orbit it's
not so bad because we're only seeing the sun
for half a route. And here's another thing.
>>Eustace: Oh go ahead. And you guys should
come up to the microphones. So if you have
a question, please.
>>Worden: Okay. Let me explain something.
You Google people particularly know the difference
between the backside and the dark side. [laughter]
You would not believe how many people do not
understand that the backside and the dark
side. Now I'm going to tell you about the
backside. It's not like the front side at
all. And I don't know how much you all look
at the Moon or try and analyze it or whatever
it is. But when you look at the Moon, your
Google Moon shows it. You see all those dark
circles on the front side of the Moon. Those
are all meteor impact spaces every single
one of them. But they were huge collisions
probably three, four billion years ago. Huge.
Those things are 500 miles across. Dave and
Jim had to fly over a 15,000 foot mountain
to get to our landing site at Hadley Rille.
That 15,000 foot mountain is the outer wave
of that meteor impact basin on Mare Imbrium
250 miles away from the center of impact.
That's how dramatic and how huge these things
were. Well, what happened is, meteor storm
came through, plastered one side of the Moon,
offset the center of gravity of the Moon.
And that's why we got one face of the Moon
looking at us all the time. That's the backside.
Of course, the dark side is just the side
away from the sun. That's what gives us the
faces. Do you have a question? Might as well.
Yeah.
>>Male #1: So first of all, thank you for
coming. In the popular media whenever you
have on return there's always the drama of
reentry where two, three, four minute blackout
period. They're wondering are the parachutes
going to come out? [grrll-grrll-grrll] What
do you guys talk about during that time? You've
got a few minutes. You're just kind of.
>> Eustace: And also you did have a parachute
problem.
>>Worden: Yeah, we were oohing and aahing
about what we were looking at on the ground
because I could see all of the North American
continent: Alaska, Siberia, Japan all the
way down to the Philippines all at the same
time. We didn't say anything because we were
looking out the window. You wait for the parachutes
to come out. There's a drag chute that comes
out at about 25,000 feet that really corrects
our descent to come down vertically and slows
us down a little bit. The main shoots come
down a 10,000 and then about 6,000 feet we
had an oh shit moment because one of the chutes
collapsed. Actually it burned up. We had a
chute that burned and as we were touching
down a second chute was burning. And that
was because we had what we called hyperbolic
fuel that we used in the RCS quads and that
fuel of course you got two different kinds
of fuel and when they touch, they burn. Well,
they're very toxic and very dangerous materials.
So we purged all the fuel lines before we
touched down to make sure we hit something
in the ocean we wouldn't burst a line and
have a problem. When we purged the fuel lines
they went up that one riser because we didn't
have any surface winds that day. Normally
the thing would be going horizontal and that
fuel would be going this way, but on our day
we were stationary, coming straight down and
the fuel went straight up and it burned big
holes in one of the parachutes and it collapsed.
And just as we were touching down in the water,
the second one was starting to burn. So we
were pretty lucky we got down when we did.
That was an oh gosh moment coming down. Yeah.
>> Male #1: Thank you.
>> Worden: Yes, sir.
>> Male #2: Hi. You were talking about repeatedly
talking about flying the lunar module or the
command module. It was occurring to me that
maneuvering a spacecraft has got to be very
different than atmospheric flight. You've
got an atmosphere to maneuver against to slow
you down. I'm wondering if the reactions that
you learned as an atmospheric pilot today
are they applicable to space flight today?
Are they a possibly even a hindrance.
>> Worden: Interesting question. The difference
between flying an airplane and flying a spacecraft
is when you're flying an airplane you're always
going forward, hopefully. And when you fly
a spacecraft, you're going in any direction,
doesn't make any difference. We actually flew
towards the Moon backwards, which didn't affect
our location. But we went in backwards because
we had to do a retrograde maneuver behind
the Moon to slow down to stay in lunar orbit.
So we never saw the Moon until we were at
60 miles. That was a point in the flight when
we really put our faith in mission control
to make sure. But when you're in space, there's
no restriction on attitude or anything. You
can point in any direction. That spacecraft
is going to go that way no matter what you
do unless you actually fire an engine to change
your velocity vector. But if you don't change
your velocity vector, you're going in that
direction and there's nothing you can do about
it. And you can roll you can do anything you
want. It's kind of fun. There's some things
in space that are kind of fun that we can't
do down here. Along that line, we took out
the center couch one day. Well, we had it
out a lot of time because it gave us more
room to move around. We got Jim Erwin to roll
up in a ball and Dave and I stood on either
side of him started spinning. We thought that
would be kind of an neat experiment to run
up there and he's spinning. He's all curled
up in a ball. Okay Jim stick your arm out.
Slowed right down. Pull his arm in. Speed
right up. So that was kind of fun. We didn't
let that go on too long because we were afraid
Jim would get sick. [laughter] But space is
an entire, there's another dimension that
we're going to have to get used to if we really,
not getting used to. We got used to it pretty
quickly on our flight. But learning how to
deal with it in a flight kind of way to go
somewhere, we're going to have, there are
going to be a lot of studies, a lot of research,
a lot of development on it.
>> Male #2: Thank you.
>> Male #3: Hi. I admire you for challenging
the impossible and doing amazing things.
>> Worden: Didn't know it was impossible.
I probably wouldn't have tried it if I thought
it was impossible. [laughter]
[laughter]
>>Male #3: It's been 40 years since the heyday
of the Apollo program. And today we've given
up our manned flight capability. What do you
think it will take to get America back into
space?
>> Worden: New president. I think that's the
big key to it. He doesn't like space. And
I'm not being, I'm being quite serious about
that. But maybe not in the way you might think.
Space flight to me, it's nice. We're going
to go somewhere eventually so we got a place
to go when the Earth's when we can't live
here anymore. That might be a billion years
from now. So there's no big rush. But it's
going to happen. There's a genetic drive in
us that says, "We're going to go into space
regardless." And we may go through cycles
and it may be 100 years between cycles and
it may be 50 years or whatever. Right now
we're in the bottom of a cycle and I do believe
that it's going to come back because we're
going to keep pressing on. The big problem
is propulsion. So we're going to take some
time to resolve or to solve the propulsion
problem. But I believe that we have that genetic
drive that's going to push us out there to
the point where we're going to find another
planet where we can live on it someday. Like
I say may be a billion years from now. So
right now we're in kind of the doldrums. But
the problem I have with us shutting down programs
is two things. One is that the program is
responsible one way or another for an awful
lot of technology development in the last
50 years. I believe that we wouldn't have
silicon chips today if the government and
the military and NASA hadn't supported the
development of silicon chips. Now, we're way
beyond that today. We're into mems. We're
into Nano technology that's way beyond the
original silicon chip. But I guarantee you
that the success this country has had in the
last 40 years basically is based on the silicon
chip. Everything we've got has a silicon chip
in it, my watch, everything. That watch incidentally
has got more memory capacity than my computer
on board. [laughter] But I do believe that
when we decide that we're going to back off
from a technology development program such
as the space program, then we got problems.
That's leading into keeping businesses very,
very productive in this country. The other
thing that we're going to lose which I think
is really dreadful is the motivation for young
people to go to school. I think in the last
40 years the greatest motivator that young
people have had not only to go to school but
get good grades and follow it through is the
possibility they might work in a space program
someday. And I have to tell young people today
hey we're in the doldrums, now we got this
guy who doesn't like space so we're really
not doing much right now. I'm well I'm not
happy with the attitude. And it's not just
Obama. It's the whole Washington scene that
I'm not happy with today. They really lost
track of what this country is all about. But
I really think that young people today without
us having an active manned space program.
That's kind of taking it on faith it's going
to come back and that's a tough sell.
>> Male #3: Great answer. Thank you.
>> Male #4: You started off talking about
the role of astronauts as pilots and contrasting
it with the Soviet Union's approach where
the Cosmonauts were really more like passengers
in many ways. In his book The Right Stuff,
Tom Wolfe makes a big deal about according
to him the American engineers originally wanted
to treat the astronauts as they like to say
in the book 'spam in a can or monkey in a
bucket' and that the astronauts had to kick
up a huge fuss in order to retain their role
as pilots. Is that really a realistic account
of how that worked and that happened in your
experience or is this just Tom Wolf ripping
a good yarn?
>> Worden: Well, I think Tom got it mostly
right. He's a great writer. And I spent a
lot of time with him when he wrote that book.
There's always a problem, a difference of
opinion about how you do things. How much
automation do put into something? How much
manual control do you put into something?
How do the two integrate together? How do
you manage all of that? Yes, some of the original
seven guys were pretty strong about flying
that thing. And the Mercury was pretty much,
as you probably are aware and many of you
studied all this stuff was that Scott Carpenter
had a lot of problems on his flight because
he couldn't manually get it to where it's
supposed to be for reentry and that got him
into a lot of trouble 200 miles down range.
As far as I know I haven't heard an argument
that says we needed to do it more manually
than we were doing it. We were pretty set
on doing all the flying ourselves. Now, we
had a computer that helped us a lot. We never
developed a system that would allow the ground
to automatically dock one of our spacecraft
to the International Space Station. We don't
have that program. They got to do it manually.
And I don't recall there ever being discussion
to make it any more automated than that.
>>Male #4: Thank you.
>>Worden: Mm-hmm.
>> Male #5: Two questions if I may. First
one is vis-à-vis your comment about the doldrums
we're in today with respect to space exploration.
What's your perspective about the role of
private industry?
>> Worden: Private industry in space.
>> Male #5: Sure.
>> Worden: Gee. My attitude about that is
pretty well-known I think.
>> Eustace: We just talked about that at lunch,
you know. It's controversial. It's great.
>> Worden: Well, yeah. Private industry will
probably have a role in space at some point.
They might be the taxi cab to get to the International
Space Station. Private industry will not take
us beyond that. They can't. They won't. Why?
What's the goal of private industry? Make
a profit. If they can't see a profit in a
program, then they're probably not going to
do it. They can see a profit in taking guys
up to the space station because they're customer,
the U.S. government, is going to pay them.
My attitude about that is if we're going to
pay somebody to take us to the International
Space Station and we're going to provide them
with a profit to do that, we might as well
take that money do it ourselves. I don't believe
in a third man, I think the flip side of that
is the government tends not to be very efficient
about things that they do so it costs a lot
more money and private industry's going to
get right to the heart of it. But I'm also
concerned private industry is going to get
the bare bone stuff to get a guy up there
and back. There may be some corners that get
cut short. There may be some things that are
left out that shouldn't be. I don't know that
for a fact. But I know that when I got a,
when I've got a project and it's got a cost
limit to it and I got to do certain things
with that then I'm going to jam that program
into there to make sure I do it for the money.
The government doesn't have that restriction.
If it runs into a problem, it's going to fix
the problem. The government's interest in
all of this is safety for the crew. Private
industry's interest in all of this is a profit.
I see that as a big change. At the same time,
I don't see private industry ever going beyond
the Earth orbit. Because what private company
is going to send a crew to Mars let's say
on the off chance that there might be something
there that might be profitable? I don't see
that happening. So the government's role in
all this is going the long range stuff and
private industry is going to do just the Earth
orbital stuff. And so far there are some companies
that are working on it. We'll see how they
do. I'm probably not as optimistic about it
as I should be.
>> Male #5: And the second question very quickly.
It struck me earlier you mentioned when you
were training and guiding the spaceship that
you guided this blue sort of ridge or blue
line in the atmosphere. How do you train for
that on Earth? I can't imagine you saw the
same thing down here as you saw up there.
>> Worden: It's projected on a screen. But
it was all connected to a very sophisticated
computer program that measured all those things.
It was done at MIT at the Stark Draper labs
and they designed the whole lab system that
we used. And I don't think we could have done
it without them. You know, Draper labs started
doing inertial navigation for submarines years
and years and years ago and they designed
ours too. Let me tell you a good example.
We're gone two weeks. We had one attitude,
we had one inertial reference if you will.
It's a three-axis frame with a gyro on each
axis and we had to adjust that inertial reference
frame as we went because it would drift. There's
no way you could prevent it from drifting
a little bit. But what those guys at MIT did
for us is they worked out a program that kept
track of the drift rates and after we had
a realigned the platform after a couple of
days the computer then took over and pulsed
each of the three x's on the inertial reference
platform just enough to take out the drift
that was in there. We never touched that thing
again the whole flight. Now we had one gyro
onboard to go all the way to the Moon and
back. The shuttle has three, okay, just to
go to the Earth's orbit. We had one computer.
The shuttle had 4. Guess which has the greatest
probability of success? Ours. Of course the
problem is is we're either 100% or 0. You
take the shuttle you take the probability
of success of the computer system in the shuttle
each of them are like 0.95%. Well, you got
to multiply all four of them out and you got
a fairly low reliability number when you end
up. And that's kind of the situation we found
out too. The philosophy back in the Apollo
program was build one, test the heck out of
it, make sure it's right, and use it on the
flight. Now our gyro was probably ten years
old when we flew. It was an air bearing gyro,
but it was only one. Guess what we had if
we lost the gyro, okay? Let's say we lost
the gyro or we lost our computer in flight.
We lost something that where we lost any information
we needed on where we were and where our attitude
was and all that. In other words we had no
attitude no location. What did we do? Well,
we had a backup for that. Our back up was
a telescope. Kind of. Actually, it was a World
War II; it was a World War II fighter optical
gun site. And we had the crosshairs on a gun
site and we'd mount that in the window and
you could line up the two cross hairs and
the ground would tell us which star to line
up on. That would give us our attitude. It
doesn't make any difference what your role
is as long as your central axis is pointing
to that star. And it would tell us how much
to fire the engines, two feet per second,
or five feet per second on a certain direction
that would get us back home. So we had a very
good way of getting back home even if we lost
everything except the radio. But the attitude
was we're going to take something that's very,
very reliable, we're going to test it to the
point where we are absolutely convinced it's
going to work. We never had a problem in the
Apollo program going that way so it was kind
of a neat thing.
>>Male #6 Can you tell us a little bit about
your duties when you're alone in orbit and
why the Apollo capsule required a babysitter?
>> Worden: Well, I'm sorry, I didn't get the.
>> Male #6: Why did the Apollo capsule require
a babysitter? Why couldn't it be left unmanned?
>>Worden: Left unmanned? You got to be kidding.
[laughter]
>>Male #6: It was during Skylab.
>> Worden: I don't agree. Constellation is
thinking about doing that and I do not agree
with that. Like I said before, my example
of soup floating around inside, if something
like that happens and that thing is unmanned,
you got a problem, a big problem. Something
as simple as a little water leak in that that
command module could destroy it. The original
idea for Constellation was to go to the Moon,
send the whole crew to the surface, leave
the command module in orbit, station keeping
by itself without somebody on board. I totally
disagree with that because in six months you
better believe that something's going to go
wrong. So I don't believe, I think that's
a very, very dangerous philosophy.
>> Eustace: You kept pretty busy up there
too.
>>Worden: Well, I had-
>>Eustace: Your schedule in that command module
is grueling.
>> Worden: We did. Basically I worked 20 hours
a day. I had a lot of things, some really
exciting things too. But the basic stuff I
did was I photographed with the high resolution
camera. Like on your Google Moon, I think
some of that's mine. And with the mapping
camera that had a laser altimeter that took
the altitude in the middle of the picture.
Carried a whole bunch of remote sensing devices
that were on extendible poles, like I had
an x-ray spectrometer, gamma ray spectrometer
had a mass spectrometer. I forget the other
ones but we had five of them that I used to
scan the surface of the Moon. And the idea
was these were the remote sensing devices
that were complimentary to the chemistry of
the rocks we thought we'd see on the surface.
So when Dave and Jim brought rocks back they
did a chemical composition analysis and then
they compared that with what we got from remote
sensing and now we can go to the Moon without
landing and find out what the chemical composition
of the surface is anywhere we want to look
just doing it remotely. So that was one of
the things. So I'm, those poles are coming
in and out and all that. Tell you another
little story. We had a mass spectrometer.
It was on a 30-foot pole that went out of
the, you know to get it outside any influence
that the spacecraft might have. That was to
check if there were any particles in lunar
orbit. So we're up there going round and round.
Ground calls to me. I'm by myself up there.
Ground calls and they says, "We're picking
up something on the mass spectrometer." "Oh,
that's interesting." "Something is until the
atmosphere, we'll let you know." So they called
me back a few hours later and said we figured
out what it is." I said, "Oh, okay what is
it?""Chemical composition it's urine." [laughter]
And I said, "Gee, that's interesting since
we had just done a urine dump about four revolutions
before. So we're picking up ourselves in lunar
orbit as were goin' around. So I was very
busy and I did a lot of visual observations.
We had really trained hard on the features
of the Moon because there was still a lot
of discussion about whether the features were
formed by meteor impacts or by volcanism,
volcanoes. So we had a lot of that, as a matter
of fact, I found a field of cinder cones which
many of you know is kind of a last eruption.
And in fact, when we got back that was verified
and they changed the landing site for Apollo
17 to go to that area. That was kind of a
neat thing. I also took a lot of, I did some
really interesting photography I thought.
I did what we call low-light level photography.
I don't know. You're all too young. You didn't
even know anything about film. But back in
those days, we carried film. And I had a,
I managed to carry on the flight a camera
that was made by Nikon. It had a lens that
was a 1.01 lens which was like 99.99% clear.
And I carried a film that was ASA of 5,000.
Film, normal film back in those days -- was
like ASA 400, 300, 200 something like that.
I carried a film that was 5,000. It was a
special film for very low-light phenomena.
And I guarantee you I could go outside of
crew quarters down at the Cape and take a
picture of the parking lot where it's totally
black. All there was was sky glow and it would
look like daylight. This film was that good.
So I took pictures of very low-light phenomenon.
And I'll tell you what they are. One of them
are your LaGrange points and if you know your
LaGrange points there are five of them. Three
of them in a row on a line through the center
of the Earth and the center of the Moon. There
are 2 offset the two offset are stable equilibrium
points. There's a thing in this country called
the L 5 society which is focused on Le grange
point No. 5 as being the perfect place for
a space station which is correct by the way.
Because it's stable, it's stable equilibrium.
It's a stable equilibrium point. If you put
something there, it's going to stay there.
If you perturb something at that point, push
it out, then all the dynamics of that point
pull it back in. That's true there should
be a dust cloud at L 5, right? There should
be something there if you could get a picture
of it. Nobody ever got a picture of this.
So I got out with my low-light camera and
I did ten second exposures with ASA 5,000
film. That's unbelievable. You cannot stop
the smear. You can't keep the spacecraft that
steady for five or ten seconds. But even with
the smear, yes there is a cloud of dust there.
So we know. The other thing I took these low-light
double pictures of is a thing called the Gegenschein.
The Gegenschein is outside the last planet.
It's a ring of loose unconsolidated rock.
When the solar system was formed it's rock
that never formed a planet and it's outside.
And all it is is this rink of rock and if
you go to the highest mountain in the Himalayas
or in the Andes or somewhere like that, you
get out of most of the atmosphere you can
sometimes see it because what you see is reflection
of sunlight off all though particles. Got
pictures of that too. So there's a lot of
really, really interesting stuff we did in
addition to focusing on the Moon itself. I'll
tell you something that blew my mind. There
was a portion of my orbit where I was on the
backside and on the dark side at the same
time. It was just like a pie-shaped wedge
around the side of the Moon. And from that
vantage point the thing that really captured
my imagination was the rest of the universe
out there. All of a sudden we had 37 stars
that were the brightest stars in the sky that
I used as navigation stars. When I got to
that sector of the orbit around the Moon I
couldn't find them because there were so many
stars. I could not pick out an individual
star anywhere because there was just a wash
of light. You see every star and you can't
pick out an individual star. It's absolutely
amazing. You never believe what the faint
stars get cut off by the scene or the absorption
through the atmosphere. So what we really
look at through the atmosphere here is the
brightest stars. You get outside the atmosphere,
they're all coming at you. And I could absolutely
define the horizon of the Moon by the light
that was cut off, not by the light shining
on it. So that made me do a little research
and I'm sure there are people here that know
this a lot better than I know it. What it
made me think about is, "What's the rest of
the universe like?" It's one thing to look
back at the Earth, we come from it, we know.
It's the most colorful thing in the Solar
System. When you look at the rest of the universe,
you got to put on a different hat. Realize
we're a part of the Milky Way galaxy. We look
at through it sideways. We don't look from
it on top. We go through it sideways. And
the estimate of the number anybody know how
many stars are in the Milky Way galaxy? Anybody
got an idea?
>>Audience: 200 billion.
>>Worden: Exactly. 200 billion, 200 billion
with a B and I've seen estimates as high as
400 billion. But I think 200 billion is a
reasonable number. 200 billion stars in our
own little galaxy? C'mon. Now how many galaxies
are out there?
>>Audience: 100 billion.
>>Worden: There you go. And that's only because
that's as far as we can see. So you got 100
billion times 200 billion. There are a few
stars out there. [laughter]
>>Eustace: You, you-
>>Worden: The whole point is, we as people
as a thinking species, we don't have a clue.
We don't have a clue. Anybody wants to talk
about search for extraterrestrial intelligence?
Right on man. It's out there. Now, people
ask me about UFOs, I say, "bring me a piece
of one. That's the only way you're going to
convince me." But is there life out there?
Absolutely. No question about it. Probably
a lot smarter than we are. That's why they
don't come.
[laughter]
>> Eustace: Okay. With that I'd like to thank.
[Applause]